für mich bist du noch viel mehr als ein
diamant in der wüste er wollte was geht
ab und bekommen bei einem neuen video
hier mal wieder auf einem kanal und so
und ja heute geht es darum so ein paar
dinge wie man eigentlich so fast jedes
mädchen ziemlich stark beeindrucken kann
ich hoffe zumindest dass es klappen wird
könnt ihr dann selber ausprobieren ich
will gar nicht lange land viel spaß und
haut rein
ich mache es auch mal so passau sollen
dann würde ich mal sagen wir fangen an
mit punkt nummer eins und zwei ist ja
manchmal echt wichtig so eine mädchen zu
zeigen dass man selber so richtig cool
ist und alt überzeugen kann und dabei
ist es natürlich auch nicht ganz so
schlimm wenn man das ein oder andere mal
vielleicht ein bisschen übertreibt auf
ein bisschen liegt seit ende ein
bisschen kreativ wir nehmen jetzt mal
als beispiel hier seid gerade irgendwie
auf dem weg zu ihr und denkt euch dabei
einfach so eine übels kasse story ein
macht dabei eure haase aus sondern eben
auch so dreck und kräften euch so ins
gesicht und man sich jetzt scheißegal
und dann wenn ihr daran grund fragt sie
natürlich nach und was hast du denn gold
und sagt ihr einfach so ich werde auf
dem weg zu dir dann haben sich nur zwei
gekloppt dann bin ich dazwischen
gedanken habe ich noch eine taube
gerettet die fast gestorben ist soler
kam und so nadler hat mich angegriffen
wolle mir meine haare clown aber die
konnte ich dann noch festhalten
irgendeine scheiße probiert es einfach
mal aus also ich war das aus ziemlich
oft bei meiner freundin und klappt
eigentlich auch so umfasst die combo
schon zu punkt 2 und zwar könnt ihr mit
diesem punkt so richtig zeigen dass ihr
wirklich oder dass ihr euch wirklich
richtig wichtig ist und zwar macht ihr
es einfach so in dem ihr so tut als
hättet ihr euren ganzen tag schon so
richtig fahrplan und eigentlich gar
keine zeit haben und wenn sie denn jetzt
fragt ob ihr vielleicht an diesem tag
zeit habt dann könnt ihr natürlich erst
mal so ja ich habe eigentlich schon mit
dem und dem was vor aber ihr sagt dann
auch du bist mir so wichtig ich sage das
einfach ab obwohl er eigentlich gar
nichts vorhabt überlegt doch mal ich
meine es doch eigentlich eine richtig
gute methode denn im gegensatz dazu
denkt sich dann natürlich auch manchmal
der sagt immer seine verabredung ab und
blablabla dann muss ich das gleiche doch
vielleicht auch mal machen und dann hat
sie auch öfter zeit eigentlich ganz
praktisch kommen wir auch schon zu punkt
3 und zwar könnt ihr euch bei dieser
sache entweder übels krass blamieren
oder sie feiert euch heft
ich und mache ich danach noch mehr ist
aber eigentlich ganz einfach und zwar
geht ihr dazu einfach auf google und
google nach so ein paar liebes sprüchen
die ihrem schwarm sagen können so gibt
ein liebes sprüche die ich ein mädchen
sagen können irgendwie sowas ich ernenne
euch einfach mal ein beispiel damit ihr
so bisher auf den geschmack und für mich
bist du noch viel mehr als ein diamant
in der wüste
doch in der wüste oder eine rose im
schnee okay sind wir mal ehrlich die
chance ist schon ziemlich hoch dass ihr
direkt wieder kommen hier ich bin ich
von dir weg und da kommt auch schon zum
letzten tipp und zwar zu tipp 74 seiten
dass sie vielleicht mal euer whatsapp so
abdeckt und zwar ist es ganz einfach ihr
liegt ein neuer handy da hin und sagt
ihr jedoch toller typ
am besten nehmen sie aber vorher noch
ein pin raus weil sonst kommt sie
logischerweise nicht rein und zwar müsst
ihr sie darauf aufmerksam machen dass
sie wirklich das einzige mädchen ist mit
dem ihr schreibt dazu geht ihr einfach
auf whatsapp guckt dann die anderen
mädchen hier lange draufdrücken chat
löschen
ganz einfach ein problem weniger was zu
diesem tipp auch noch gut dazu passt da
sie ja eh whatsapp checkt sag ich mal
und dann wahrscheinlich auf sich selber
darin gespeichert weil jetzt die einfach
süß eine wie traum oder irgendwo und so
eine scheiße war so ein spontanes video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen sollte
jetzt nicht so ernst gemeint sein
vielleicht könnt ihr den ein oder
anderen tipp ja wirklich mal
ausprobieren schreibt mir dann eure
ergebnisse in die kommentare
ansonsten was ist natürlich mit dem
video wenn es euch gefallen hat würde
mich freuen gibt daumen hoch oder so
instagram und co alles und in der video
beschreibung abonnieren nicht vergessen
weil er nichts mehr verpassen wollte
danke für 9000 abonnenten sind wir auch
schon wieder und ja hier auf der linken
seite geht es weiter mit meinem letzten
video und da war so ein bisschen was
über die wm
und hier auf der rechten seite mit dinge
wie die jungs beziehungsweise mädchen
waren jack auf jeden fall beides macht
und wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich nächste
woche nicht wieder da ich im urlaub bin
ansonsten schöne ferien weil sie die
schon ab und haut rein